so president Donald Trump went to Puerto
Rico yesterday the horrifying disaster
took place there this was after Donald
Trump responded to the mayor of San
Juans pleas for help to save lives with
criticisms on Twitter and calling Puerto
Rican people who want everything handed
to them effectively lazy Trump arrived
in Puerto Rico yesterday and he gave
what is possibly the most insensitive
and boneheaded speech we've seen him
give so far and that really says a lot
from what we've seen in these first
eight or nine months he told Porto
Ricans that this fortunately wasn't a
real catastrophe like Hurricane Katrina
years ago and that in the end only 16
people died and of course he blamed
Puerto Ricans for having to spend money
on them of course the death toll has
since increased sadly I read the
headline and I thought has to be a fake
article right it has to be the onion or
some kind of satire but no and we have
video and we have video of this abortion
of a presidential visit to Puerto Rico
I would not allow kids to see this let's
take a look now I hate to tell you Porto
Rico but you've thrown our budget a
little out of whack because we've spent
a lot of money on Puerto Rico and that's
fine we've saved a lot of lives if you
look at the every death is a horror of
course but if you look at a real
catastrophe like Katrina oh and you look
at the tremendous hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of people that died and you
look at what happened here with really a
storm that was just totally overpowering
nobody's ever seen anything like this
now what is your what is your death
count as at this moment 17 16 people
certified right 16 people versus in the
thousands you can be very proud of all
of your people all of our people working
together 16 versus literally thousands
of congratulations only 16 people died
everything is a penis sized contest with
Trump everything he's comparing
disasters like they're competitions of
some kind but is anybody really
surprised the guy bragged after 9/11
about having the tallest building
in lower Manhattan because the twin
towers had been knocked down by
terrorists
now Melania looks comatose right she
looks like she's trying to stay as still
as possible
maybe if she doesn't move she'll blend
into the background because this is just
horrifying to anyone with any semblance
of common sense and the governor of
Puerto Rico sitting to Trump's right we
have a zoomin isolated on the moment
that he moves into downright confusion
he looks like he's being held hostage by
the worst torturer in the world check
this out we're gonna zoom in on him and
just look at his facial expression as
Trump says these absolute atrocities if
you look at the every death is a horror
but if you look at a real catastrophe
like Katrina and you look at the
tremendous hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of people that died and you
look at what happened here with really a
storm that was just totally overpowering
nobody's ever seen anything like this
look at his face I mean we we have I've
been looking at this like it's the
Zapruder film from the Kennedy
assassination look at his face as Donald
Trump is saying these things it does
seem like dementia or I was thinking
actually may be persistent sleep
deprivation Trump's been bragging for
decades about only sleeping for night
four hours per night or so if you've
been doing that for 50 years it's
probably the equivalent of acting like
you have the early you're in the early
stages of dementia Trump is
congratulating them on having had 16
people die not that it matters to Trump
but again the death toll has increased
so that this reminds me there's a scene
in Breaking Bad one of my favorite TV
shows season three episode one where
after there's a plane crash in the
series Walter white played of course by
Bryan Cranston is speaking in the school
gym of the school where he teaches and
he's sort of doing this exact same thing
he says something like listen neither of
the two planes was full it was what like
2/3 or 3/4 full it's it's really like
the 50th worst airplane crash it's tied
for 50th it's almost indistinguishable
from the speech that Trump gave at
another moment Trump showed up and
started
throwing paper towels to people like he
was shooting free-throws in basketball
very bizarre video that were showing you
here and just just very strange he's
shooting them like he's shooting
basketball free-throws and everything's
just a competition I totally lost we're
showing this video and it was stunning
he can't relate to anyone I mean why
didn't all these Puerto Ricans just fly
away from the hurricane and their
private helicopters
nobody knows no one's asking that
question Trump wonders Trump also took
the opportunity to talk about how great
his staff have been shadows of george w
bush's now-infamous brownies doing a
heck of a job during katrina
brock long from fema he's great he's
unbelievable actually I think the word
is that the Trump used John Kelly he's
doing great he's a former Marine and at
the briefing in Puerto Rico Trump used
these words to describe members of an
administration who were in the room with
him a plus fantastic unbelievable great
amazing and special it's the Trump
celebration trip that's what it is
and this goes beyond just lack of
compassion and total insensitivity it's
mind-blowing stupidity when Trump opens
his mouth I imagine a cloud of the most
vile despicable ideas flowing out like
air pollution and you know who I really
am feeling bad for imagine being a
history teacher in 15 or 20 years and
having to teach this garbage to our
children imagine that job for a moment
and sometimes when I see a headline like
Trump tells Puerto Ricans at least it's
not as bad as Katrina I wish that this
would end up being fake news because
it's so horrible but every single time
it ends up being all too real the video
you just finished watching was made
possible by you through the membership
program you can sign up for membership
at david pakman.com slash membership we
are viewer supported independent media
you can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership